reported breach of the national security
agencies described as catastrophic and
even worse than Edward Snowden's massive
data leak the New York Times reports a
group called shadow brokers has been
releasing information on NSA cyber
weapons since August 2016 it's now being
used against the United States
The Times reports the government does
not know if the secrets were leaked or
hacked or whether the possible leaker is
still at work
CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is a former
deputy and acting director the CIA is
with us now from Washington good morning
Michael let me begin with this how
damaging is this what do we know about
the damage to our national security
Charlie the only thing we know so far
are the tools that have been posted on
the internet for sale we don't know what
else the leakers may have and most
important charlie we don't know how this
information got out of the National
Security Agency and that's 15 months
after the first leak occurred that's
what's most scary to me because that
says we don't know the totality of this
and more important we don't know if
they're stealing information as we sit
here right now is it worse than Edward
Snowden leaked in 2013
Norah I think so because he leaked
descriptions of these tools these are
the actual tools themselves so what are
the risk here Michael do you think for
the average American so I think there's
two Gail the first is that we used these
tools to collect intelligence on our
adversaries to protect the country we've
now made that much more difficult to
collect that intelligence that's so
important the second is that some of
these tools are being used against the
United States government and against US
companies today so they're being turned
back against us so essentially the
technology that we developed at Fort
Meade is now being used by other
governments to hack into some of our
companies and our personal information
that's exactly right Nora so we think it
was a government then so we don't know
charlie
some people are pointing fingers at
Russia I'm not so sure about that
because if Russia had access to NSA in
terms of a cyber Internet access or in
terms of an insider
why would they go public and give that
up I tend to think this is either a
disgruntled insider or an outside group
let's turn now to the President Trump in
Vietnam saying once again that he
believes that he believes Putin's
denials that their government did not
interfere with our election is this
treasonous I'm not sure it's treason as
Nora but it certainly shows that the
president is is gullible to being
manipulated by Vladimir Putin Putin is a
guy who was a trained intelligence
officer he was trained to manipulate
people and that's exactly what he did
here with President Trump did he say
that he believed him or did he simply
say that true that he thought Putin was
sincere or he believed what he said and
later said that he cast his boat with
our national security people right well
he did change his tune Charlie to the
latter to saying you know he's with our
intelligence agencies I think the key
issue here with regard to the President
and our intelligence community is that
he seems to think that it's a political
entity a political tool and that scares
me because the last president who saw
our intelligence community that way was
Richard Nixon who then used the FBI and
the CIA inappropriately and my goodness
is that sent to US intelligence when you
see the president abroad flip-flopping
is some people say that he did well it
makes it makes them wonder whether he's
listening or not to what they say and
these are individuals who take great
risks right for this country and they're
not going to take those risks if the
president's not listening how
significant is it that the United States
is withdrawn from the TPP and then
during this trip you see these other
countries that the president was
visiting in a sense coming together with
TPP and therefore making it possible for
some kind of relationship with the
Chinese Charlie I think that's a great
question I think the most important
thing that happened on this trip is the
is the tentative agreement between 11
countries to go forward with TTP without
the United States in the room this is
going to benefit economically all of
those 11
country's we're not going to benefit and
this is also going to strengthen Chinese
influence in the region again we're the
big loser all right Michael Morell thank
you for joining us welcome